come on I have to get dressed let's go
[Music]
my name is Danielle and I love my cat
this is truffle he's really really
friendly people are just really afraid
of him because he has like a really nice
I've noticed a trend where people are
having their pets pick out different
things for them to test this got me
thinking about my cat the things that he
could pick out for me it normally takes
endless time for me to pick out an
outfit so today I'm going on a date
instead of stressing about what I'm
gonna wear like I usually would today
I'm going to let my cat with my outfit
here's the plan so we're gonna lay out
some tops at a sea of truffles picks
anything and then we're going to lay out
some pants and shoes and we'll put it
together and see what happens
[Music]
I am feeling the blue shirt in the
middle the one all the way in the last
makes me a little anxious it shows a
little more stuff we're gonna put him
down we're gonna see if he shows any any
interest oh my god trouble he's ready he
wants to go nope so very much like a cat
he's not listening so we're gonna put
the toy over and see if that helps
[Music]
okay this is the one who pets it's risky
but we're gonna do it okay so now we've
laid out the bottoms and we'll see if we
can get chocolates to pick one I mean a
black bottom makes the most sense to me
I'm not big on matchy-matchy denim so
like a lighter blue one this is so
ridiculous by the way the lighter blue
one might be weird it's not what I would
think but we'll see so here's the skirt
he pitch black just like I wanted I
usually wouldn't wear a skirt on a date
so early but let's do it I'm excited
last but definitely not least we have
all the shoes laid out please truffle if
you're listening take a plain black shoe
if my cat picks the white platform
sneakers I might quit the exam thank God
I'm pretty satisfied with this outfit
that my cat picked I knew he had a good
sense of style all right time to put it
on I love this outfit
I might have worn jeans I might have
also put higher heels on I really like
it I think it's not something I would
have put together myself
[Music]
what would you say if I told you about
my cat actually picked out this outfit
he's very beautiful yeah you're welcome
I was thinking that maybe we just go out
for some tapas bar truffles thank you we
had a great time I felt really
comfortable it was really weird to talk
about with my cat in my lap we like had
a couple drinks we talked and we had a
lot of fun whatever you're wearing
confidence is what matters the most
truffles definitely got me a second date
I am confident in that